what makes you a good partner
i i genuinely i would date myself
if i could i love the confidence but
not in a bad way but i just love hanging
out with myself
i'm not telling yourself
in a good way now
hey
hello how are you doing i'm good how are
you where about you from i'm from norway
[Music]
no really yeah
it sounded irish really nice yeah yeah i
know norway it's like yeah up north of
england yeah yeah where are you from um
i am
i'm actually english
but i'm also half assadian really yes
i've got big
nose
roman yeah so no lies who dumped who in
your last relationship i dumped him
definitely yeah definitely
okay my last full-on relationship was
three years ago yeah um and we were
together for three years and
i
didn't find him attractive right yeah
and i didn't realize yeah so i was just
in this friendship relationship living
together situation he ended up cheating
on me and then i was like
no i'm done with it it's not about you
i my ex-girlfriend they're always crazy
um
so the last one was yeah i got rid of
her because she's just goes beautiful
i'm sorry that's a very nice way of
talking yeah no i was joking so i
thought it was part of my friends um
i
uh
decided this wasn't great so party
company because yeah it's just crazy
like recording me and stuff in my house
it was mental
and then another one the one before that
punched me in the face what did he do to
deserve it oh chatting to some girl in
the bar with the chicken but it wasn't
like that
i was wearing a watch outfit holding my
float some girl took it off me on the
dance floor and i said i want my float
back and she's just messing about bam in
my face yeah that's not even okay
from there yeah
what are your thoughts on the universe
and basically why do you think we exist
oh wow um
i've never thought about life really
have you never
uh
yeah but if you do you get depressed
because like you start thinking like
is it real
do you know what i mean and then
sometimes i think that i think
i think that i think life and then when
i think that's what happens if you get
what i mean yeah yeah you don't do it
you are interesting so i'm sitting here
and then i think oh that microphone's
going to fall on my head
and then it doesn't
yeah because then some because everyone
tells me oh yeah you can
mentally make things happen but like
matilda yeah and with the cheerios box
and she stares at it there's like two
different things that's telepath
telepathy tell it
tell that i don't know tell us no when
you're not scared when you teleport
no
i don't know yeah anyway that's two
different things you say what do you
think why are we here what's going on
well i'm very spiritual oh you like very
strong stuff yeah like my mom she is
you know a mindfulness structure she's
like
a healer like she's everything like
within the spiritual field
and so i was obviously brought up
believing
everything like ghosts and whatever i do
believe in sorry ghost is in like um
casper or ghost is in like someone
coming back and yeah like people yeah
being hooked with you
i was gonna hang out with the ghost like
that's kind of cool you've gotta hang
out with them but they come and hang out
with you because apparently i've seen
things where you'll be standing at a bar
and then like next minute ghosts having
a pike next to you because they're come
back to see you and stuff
you don't believe in that i mean
why i see a lot of stuff
yeah it's i don't know it's very um
yeah it's very strange but i'm very into
you know everything from like astrology
to like
yeah you know tarot readings like i do
my own terry readings actually yeah to
be honest i've never actually thought
about it like i've heard about all those
card things and uh personally i don't
know because how do you know so i
wouldn't like be like that's ridiculous
because why i don't know why i'm here on
earth like what happened
it's so weird you know what i mean yeah
for all i know
i'm a ghost
okay so
how much makeup do you wear and how long
does it take for you to get ready
oh my god um
i love makeup yeah
uh but i prefer having a more natural
makeup look oh yeah i mean do you think
i'm wearing too much makeup
if i don't know if that's down in the
corner
so so hold on so today how long did it
take for you to get ready yeah uh so
today i used an hour and a half
normally oh yeah i would have used you
know on a daily basis i don't really
wear too much makeup on a daily basis
like what i prefer a natural look yeah
so you don't look like you've got like
it plastered on you yeah that's good
yeah that's cute um
yeah just like the natural look
obviously wear as much as you want if
you want
don't worry
okay are you lying to yourself about
something
am i
all right no no
like your personality like are you lying
to something like you told me about me i
didn't
so i
i don't know if i'm lying to myself
about something but
i'm gonna tell you another fear
okay yeah i am
scared
of
i'm scared of um
maybe committing
like um so i always think to myself
i want to be in a relationship but then
when i'm in a relationship
six actually gives you three months but
i see six it sounds better six months in
it's like there's three isn't it three
months in you're like ah i have to
commit now or i run that means you're
not really that invested in them though
like if you really found the right one i
reckon you wouldn't know that yeah
that's it that's why i've only had like
you know four or five serious things
the rest of them three months here and
there because
i haven't wanted to like commit yeah so
maybe i'm lying to myself that
i'm i'm i'm ready to become a man
i appreciate the honesty is it important
to you that i make a lot of money
i'm not saying i do i'm saying it's
important yeah i mean um
i wouldn't say it's the most important
thing
uh
but i do have a lifestyle that would
require me to earn money myself so i
wouldn't be i mean it's not a
requirement for for you to earn much
money but i'm gonna earn money myself no
i agree 100 it's nice having nice things
yeah but
i'm thinking life's pretty stressful so
you know working every day on the tubes
sweating under someone's armpit it's not
the dream so what i was thinking is is
i was hoping to move to italy come off
the treadmill of life in maybe three
years or so four years maybe save up a
bit and go
and then live the simple life because
life's short
but i have to check obviously um you
wouldn't usually do this on the first
date
but you have to find out like if money
is important to somebody because for me
it's more about
lifestyle i feel like having a high
quality life is so much more important
and whatever makes you happy do it like
yeah so yeah i agree with you hundred
percent oh it's like yeah you just agree
with everything yeah yeah i'm just gonna
be like yes yes yes
would you both like to go on another
date
i mean um i think you're an interesting
person yeah so i would you know
i wouldn't mind seeing you again yeah
i'll ask you oh thanks so much
yeah um yeah i think you're very nice i
feel like you're you're really nice i
would
love to
yeah take yeah let's let's keep chatting
and see
what happens
that's the most vague
answer ever
yeah definitely
because
yeah exactly playing
100
we will chat
is that a yes or no i'm so confused oh
[Music]
some of his answers to the questions
were a bit
you know
not clear
i was a bit like confused it was just he
was just confusing in general and i
thought it was a bit rude uh when he
didn't want to answer if he wanted to
see me again because i you know i
wouldn't mind if you said no but it was
like yeah no maybe like
just give me an answer
um i know hard feelings obviously but
i'm probably not gonna
see him again no
celine's really nice um
she's
um
she's nice looking
nice personality almost like too nice
but maybe that's might be going wrong i
i think maybe i need someone who's a bit
more like um strict on me like mean like
like like in charge of me um
and yeah so like usually i go for sort
of like more of like a um
like a aggie person and maybe i'm making
a mistake again
yeah maybe i should
maybe i should go for a drink
yeah
maybe she's more like marriage material
but not
not dating do you know what i mean
times are hard dates are valuable at the
moment
i mean i hate talking about politics
because it oh but you have to though you
can't avoid it
i'm not gonna kick up a huge fuss if
labour come into power and i have to pay
like it's
it doesn't phase me the tories have done
a lot of things that have affected a lot
of people's lives like people like
children have starved like are you
trying to say i like i don't want to
kick up a fast like it has to be it's
people's lives that have been affected
okay should we leave this one here no oh
no because it's an important
conversation